it's great to welcome to the program
today daniel pink who's the author of
five new york times bestsellers
including the latest the power of regret
how looking forward moves us i'm sorry
how looking backward moves us forward
published last month daniel it's great
to have you on today
hey thanks for having me
so uh i read the book with great
interest and the book both
confirms some of the intuition that we
may have about regret and also and also
tells us that some of the intuitions we
have about regretter are very very wrong
maybe to start with can you talk a
little bit about
when it comes to the idea of it's just
better to live without regrets which is
a very general principle that a lot of
people assume is just accurate can you
talk a little bit about what aspects of
that make sense and and maybe where it
falls short
well it's a i mean it's a great way to
frame the question
they're they're when we when we look we
have this idea that we should never look
backward and that we should if we feel a
spear of regret we should essentially
ignore that um and that is
actually colossally
wrong-headed advice um what the research
tells us what 50 years of science tells
us is that everybody has regrets regret
is one of the most common emotions that
human beings have uh it is ubiquitous in
the human condition it is actually part
of our cognitive machinery and so to say
that i don't look backward and i don't
experience regret runs against the
science it's just simply not how human
beings operate um so
and the truth of the matter is that
everybody you know regret regret makes
us human nearly everybody experiences
regret i mean literally except for a
very small number of people with certain
kinds of disorders everybody experiences
regret um and if we use it right it's
actually useful to us
and this is the paradox of regret this
is sort of the puzzle of regret which is
that this emotion that makes us feel bad
is ubiquitous in the human experience so
wha why and the answer is because it
helps us if we deal with it right and we
haven't been equipped to
deal with regret properly we've been
taught in some ways to ignore it when
that fails we end up getting captured by
it and what we should be doing is
confronting our regrets yeah you talk in
the book about and this doesn't seem
unique to feelings of regret but in the
book you talk about how if the thoughts
of regret become
intrusive if they become
um sort of bottomless if they become
repetitive
that they end up having a sort of
counterproductive impact and it's not
it's not good but that thinking about
the regrets in particular ways and using
them
is actually something that that is a
positive thing can you talk a little bit
about the difference between that
because some people might say well if
i'm not thinking about the regrets then
how can i use them to my advantage
well so that's great another great
another great question so it's really
i think at a broader level we haven't
been taught how to deal with negative
emotions um i think our religious
traditions actually do a better job of
equipping us to deal with negative
emotions i think secular society hasn't
done a very good job and so what happens
is that some of us ignore negative
emotions we say nope not real gotta be
positive
put our fingers in the ears that's a bad
idea uh but because we haven't been
equipped to deal with them when we do
when they intrude as you say uh they can
feel overwhelming and so we have to ask
ourselves this question about like what
are these negative feelings for they're
not for ignoring they're not for
wallowing they're for thinking about um
and they're for thinking about as you
say in a particular way and there's a a
certain process by which we can think
about our emotions and arrest that march
toward rumination arrest that march
toward getting sucked into the into the
vortex um and it's actually relatively
simple and when we do that the evidence
is is overwhelming that that reckoning
with our regrets leaning into our
regrets in some ways can help us become
better negotiators better strategists
better problem solvers better parents
and find greater meaning in life you
know it's interesting that our interview
is today and yesterday it just so
happened that during these supreme court
confirmation hearings um
particular sentences that the nominee
judge jackson had assigned in the past
were a topic of much discussion and she
was asked numerous times do you regret
the sentence you gave to this particular
individual who went on to reoffend or or
whatever the case may be and one of the
interesting things about that framework
is that it's sort of like a
results-based regret where at the time
that you that a decision is made you
don't have the information as to what
subsequently happens and the question
was based on what happened after you
decided do you regret what you did and
daniel kahneman has written about this
and in the context of it being sort of a
a cognitive limitation that we sometimes
experience can you talk a little bit
about results-oriented
thoughts about regrets
yeah i mean i i don't want to legitimize
those questions about sentencing as as
serious intellectual inquiries agreed
100 they were they were yeah uh it was
basically
performative grandstanding and dog
whistles um absolutely so by leaving
leaving that aside for leaving that
aside for a moment and i know i know
that you agree with that
um yeah i mean
this is actually there are a couple ways
at this one of them is as we were
talking about before that's a way to
arrest the march toward rumination that
is what you need to evaluate is the
decision itself not the the not what
happened subsequently because the
decision itself is something you had
control over what happened subsequently
is something you don't have control over
um and so what i found in talking to
people about their regrets is they were
actually much less outcomes than i would
have expected um that they were actually
scrutinizing that
especially when it came to a certain
kinds of regrets they were much more
willing to scrutinize the decision
itself and were less wedded to the
outcome now all of us have that
all of us have that cognitive glitch but
but what's important to understand with
with regret is that when we
evaluate our choices and when we try to
extract lessons from them we should be
evaluating the context of the decision
what we knew what situation we were in
who in some ways who we were as a person
at that moment
and
because that's something we have control
over but the outcome itself we don't
always always have control over although
the outcome does you know can give us
clues
you um in the book you categorize
regrets into sort of certain buckets
and
in that context you did this world
regret survey of 15 000 people in in
more than 100 countries can you talk
about the categories of regret that seem
to be the most impactful for people when
they look back on their lives
yeah i mean what what i found in in
collecting regrets from all over the
world as you mentioned we're now up to
over 19 000 uh regrets from over from
109 countries it's unbelievable
and what i found which is to my surprise
is that over and over again people had
the same core regrets they regretted the
same things and these regrets were less
about the domains of people's lives they
were less about oh i have a career
regret i have an education regret i mean
superficially that's what they were but
deep down there were four things that
people
seem to regret the most i'll go through
them very quickly one of them are what i
call foundation regrets foundation
regrets are if only i'd done the work
and these are regrets about small
decisions people make about health about
finances about education early in life
that
accumulate to
you know sometimes very grave
consequences later on um so things about
especially things like not saving enough
money spending too much money uh smoking
those kinds of things second one are
boldness regrets which are if only i
taken the chance these are regrets
people have where they're at a juncture
in their life they can play it safe they
can take the chance and they don't take
the chance and they often regret it and
it's everything from traveling to
speaking up to asking somebody out on a
date to starting a business and what's
interesting about those david is that
there were people who acted boldly
and it didn't work out
and many of them said
i don't love that but i'm cool with that
because i took the chance so that's a
good example of what you were talking
about before people being to my surprise
being less outcomes than i would have
expected
third category if only i done the right
thing these are people who again are at
a juncture they can do the right thing
they can do the wrong thing they do the
wrong thing they regret it bullying
marital infidelity other kinds of
cheating and finally our connection
regrets which are uh if only i'd reached
out which are about relationships um not
mostly romantic relationships just the
full spectrum of relationships we have
in our lives that if they come apart
and we don't do anything about it we end
up regretting it and and what's amazing
to me
in this research is that
is how universal
these four regrets were i mean
irrespective of you know of um of
nationality especially uh pretty much
irrespective of gender and to some
extent even irrespective of age
are there certain cultures or countries
that just have a lower level of regret
in your estimation
i don't know that's an interesting
question um i tried to get at that i
tried to get at that question in in a i
did another piece of that so the the
world record survey was a piece of
qualitative research that as i was
essentially collecting stories i also
did a piece of quantitative research
which was a um which essentially a giant
opinion poll of the american population
the largest
uh sampling of american attitudes about
regret ever conducted a pretty rigorous
quantitative survey and i tried to get
at that
a version of that question that way by
asking say
about say belief in god does a belief in
god correlate with people's regrets
zero correlation of any kind i ask
people do you give people three choices
do you believe in god which of these
best describes your belief
i believe in god i don't believe in god
i'm not sure i believe in god and
zero correlation of any kind with
with anything um i also asked people
whether they believed that in general
everything in life happened for a reason
and
most people did yet most people also
believe they had free will so
so so other ways at that question about
belief systems seem to indicate there
there wasn't much difference i mean i'm
not i'm i'm hesitant to say that def i'm
very hesitant to say that definitively
my hunch right now is that
that
the that belief systems didn't matter
all that much and it could be because
regret is so central to our
literally to our brain function that is
our brains don't have a nationality our
behavior can have a nationality because
it's our brains acting in a context but
our but the
lump of of um
of
cells in our head doesn't isn't you know
an indonesian
isn't an indonesian brain or a american
brain or a polish brain it's just a
brain and yeah red is central that makes
sense i mean at the same time there are
so many cultural ideas and memes like
you know fomo fear of missing out yolo
you only live once that aren't the same
across all countries so it would be
interesting whether you know do
brazilians tend to have fewer regrets
than danes versus americans or that type
of thing and it sounds like we don't
really have that data at least at this
point
not at all i mean in fact if you're
talking about the number of regrets i
have no idea because i because in my
surveys i ask people in the quantitative
survey i ask people to list one of their
biggest regrets in the qualitative
survey also
tell me about one big regret i didn't
ask you know so so could there could be
volume differences yeah that people in
in um
in slovenia have lots and lots of
regrets and people in uh brazil have
only one or two and yet when you look at
the top regrets the biggest regrets
there's commonality there i um the other
thing that is interesting is whether and
you i think you you touched on this in
the book a little bit i think and i've
also read articles preparing for the
interview so now i'm not sure but one of
the things is
do more opportunities create an
environment
for having more regrets whereas someone
whose life
felt like it provided fewer
opportunities reduces the amount of
regret that one might feel
yes although opportunity is also
opportunity is a little bit paradoxical
so let me give you let me give you a
piece of data on that from the
quantitative survey the american regret
project the big public opinion poll what
we found there was that people who had
high levels of formal education that is
they had degrees and advanced degrees
right those people um we know which is
which is a minority of of of americans i
think it's something like 30 percent or
so of americans have a college degree
and an even smaller percentage of that
have a so-called advanced degree and
what we found there is that those folks
the people with college degrees and
advanced degrees especially had more
career regrets than other people
which is weird because
you know that but i but it's it's so
superficially weird but it goes to
exactly to your point which is that the
fact that they had more career
opportunities might have given them a
larger universe of career opportunities
to regret right now that said
thwarted opportunity
can also be a source of regret so
opportunity sort of lives at the core of
regret but in a somewhat paradoxical way
huge numbers of opportunities can lead
to regret but reduced opportunities
can also lead to regret
last thing i want to touch on in terms
of takeaways for one's own thinking and
and actions and sort of life
one principle that i got from the book
maybe rightly maybe wrongly is in
general
there seems to be more regret for things
not done than for things done very very
broadly speaking is that true and and
what other kind of general principles
that one can apply do you think are
important
um it is
what you're saying is
very true i mean that that thing that's
that's a claim that i can make without
with very little hesitation based on the
existing research and based on my own
research and the quantitative survey
that was a very very clear finding
particularly when it comes to age uh
when we're younger we tend to have equal
regrets of of of action things i did and
in action what i didn't do as we age
overwhelmingly it's regrets of inaction
and i think that the takeaway there is
that in general in life we should have a
slight bias for action um that in some
ways we're generally over indexed on
risk uh and we're over indexed on
feelings of awkwardness uh so we think
that asking somebody out on a date has a
high level of risk when it actually
doesn't we think that reaching out to a
friend who's drifted apart it has high
levels of awkwardness but it really
doesn't uh we think and this is a little
bit
closer to the line but but we we
sometimes over index on how much risk it
is to start a business um and and so i
think that a takeaway is that we should
have a in general in life a bias for
action because action is also a way that
it's also a way that we learn things so
i think sometimes we we plan too much
and act too little we we feel like in
order to act we have to plan out
everything when in fact
acting itself is a form of planning and
understanding so i think that's one big
takeaway the other big takeaway is i
think in terms of how we reckon with our
regrets is that we should recognize that
when we feel regret it is utterly human
and that when we do that we should treat
ourselves with kindness rather than
contempt recognize that we're it's part
of the human condition we should talk
about our regrets and use language to
make sense of our regrets and we should
explicitly stop and try to extract a
lesson from those regrets so if we do
that if we say you know
this is this is this is what i regret
it's totally normal i'm going to treat
myself with kindness let me try to make
sense of it let me draw a lesson from it
and let me apply that lesson next time
then it's an incredibly productive and
even transformative emotion
the book is the power of regret how
looking backward moves us forward we've
been speaking with the book's author
daniel pink really appreciate your time
today
thanks for having me it was a pleasure